I've always felt like Ali and Hannah
could possibly in some weird twisted way
be related or be twins there's been
hints about that the funny thing is is
we they cast us to look similar because
in the books
Alison like Hannah was supposed to
replace Alison as the it girl and they
wanted them to look very similar so
Ashley now yeah we looked pretty similar
we talked about all the time like some
types of pictures we look like sisters
so you never know I mean you can't say
you can't say never on our shows do you
think that Ali will figure out this
season who she can trust who she can't
like what's going on with Jason and then
yes Ben yes she has one person that's
gonna be a very big trust issue she's
not gonna be sure about for a very long
time but other than that yes she knows
who she can trust is it Jason what's
that relationship like this season it's
it's good it's good it's not him she
knows she can there's only been one time
where she couldn't trust Jason right and
that was when we weren't sure if he was
a druggie or a nod or a but that's over
now he's great no he's a very good
brother he could trust Jason give us a
hint as to who she's having trust issues
with I would think a lot of people she
still may or may not be related to this
person